[Music]
jovanna is with us in new york newark
new jersey hey giovanna what's up
hi
um
how you doing good how can we help
yes so um i am
all in with your uh with your principles
and i am a host for the financial piece
so far twice this year and will be my
next the next class in october
but i must admit i am feeling very
discouraged um because um i don't have
any debt um and um i'm coming out of a
22 year marriage and i've always been a
stay-at-home mom and a homeschool mom
and so here i am trying to get an
apartment and they're going credit how
you get how do you get an apartment if
you don't have credit i don't want a
credit card i i don't want anything to
do with that but i feel discouraged
because how can i
get
something without credit how many of you
actually talked to
um yeah a lot actually just was going on
realtor.com and um did you actually call
the apartment complex and talk to the
manager
not the manager but the person that
would actually um answer the phone you
know
because we did a thing anthony o'neil
got anthony o'neil's on youtube we did a
thing he called 20 plus
apartments and said i'm i i have no
credit score
how much of a down payment or how much
of a deposit do i have to make and will
you rent to me and all of them but two
would rent to him
wow so i'm yeah and i'm right now in new
jersey trying to move to arizona because
my son has a scholarship opportunity out
there
and
you know
and you've actually called
20 apartments 20 20 rentals in arizona
or you just looked on realtor.com no oh
no i haven't called i haven't called 20.
i just you know i've called three
uh that is within my price range yeah
three is not enough to get discouraged
but i haven't i haven't spoke to the
manager so maybe that's why just call
them and say you have a job right
i don't well
honey that's why they don't care if you
got a credit score or not they don't
rent to you without a job
right so like i said my situation is a
little bit odd um like i said 20 22 yeah
but it's not your credit score it's a
problem
i'll rent to you without a credit score
as a as a landlord i do all the time but
i'm not going to rent to you if you
don't have a job
right so i mean my income my income is
out on in child support so i do have
that as my answer i'm not writing to you
on alimony child support because he's
not dependable
okay gotcha i have to know you can pay
the rent as the landlord yeah they're
not true for income it's not your credit
score plus you've only actually talked
to three
you're not allowed to get discouraged
when you talk to three and that's your
sample size talk to 30
tell them what's going on maybe one of
them will run to you with child support
and alimony
if you can live on that